so the lawsuit between scarlett
johansson and the disney corporation has
been resolved this was honestly always
what was going to happen and it was also
probably always going to be resolved
with undisclosed terms which is also
what happened the thing is everyone did
these big speculations about the
possible implications of the lawsuit if
one side or the other one but the thing
is
the stakes were too high
if it had actually gone to court and
johansen had won then whatever terms the
court said she was entitled to would be
something that disney would be expected
to grant to
all actors of her stature going forward
and if she had gone to court and lost
then pretty much any actor can forget
about trying to get the kinds of terms
that she was suing over so both sides
had way too much to lose this way
johansen got enough to get what she
wanted disney doesn't have to disclose
the terms which means they don't have to
offer that to anybody else because it's
not public record
this was always going to happen